[Musique]
scènes de confusion et de désordre dans
le midwest américain
la divulgation des résultats des caucus
démocrate de l'iowa a complètement
déraillé cette semaine disons que ça
tombe mal quand on sait qu'il s'agit
d'une étape cruciale du processus de
sélection de la personne qui affrontera
dans le groupe à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 valent cher j'ai
tout entendu cas au fiasco catastrophe
bien dire ce qui est arrivé un an toutes
ces choses le parti démocrate a décidé
d'utiliser une application pour ces
caucus se tenait une nouvelle
application d'une compagnie qui
s'appelle shadows in qui souhaitent
exposer de faciliter le caucus donc de
transmettre les résultats très
rapidement au parti démocrate pour que
les instances plus d'eau ni le gagnant
de dans les médias la population ça peut
pas être proposée est ce qui est arrivé
hafner pas fonctionner l'application
plants est tout simplement donc la cause
d'un imbroglio dans le processus on n'a
pas pu avoir les résultats le soir même
parce que l'application ne fonctionné
conséquence comme uhh uhh celle au
moment avant que les premiers résultats
soit finalement divulgué il y avait tout
un vide mais oui qu'est-ce qui arrive
d'install la nature n'aime pas le vide
on savait que bobby sands et est donné
favori dans les sondages est là
l'application plants le jour vous pu
disposer de gagner la première primat du
titre des théories comme quoi le c'était
orchestrée par le parti démocrate pour
miner la candidature de bernie sanders
qui a pas aidé c'est que son rival picb
origin ge a déclaré victoir mince on
n'avait pas de résultats il te lis pas
une conférence de presse pour dire qu'il
avait gagné et là on a appris en
fouillant un peu sur le web que petit
bolide j'avais donné de l'argent la
compagnie qui a créé l'application
boeing
donc l'on disait qu'il avait investi
avec des gens qui comprenant des tweets
qu'il était un des co fondateurs de
cette entreprise là en fait ce pauvre
gré y avait acheté des services à cette
entreprise nommée burry stander ou s'ils
avaient acheté des services et des
services de messagerie à cette
entreprise a donc ça n'a rien à voir
bref ça crie toute sorte de confusion
autour de ça et les gens s'accuser
mutuellement des des robots on disait
qu'il y avait des robots russe way qui
avait dit
quand les russes finalement les rachats
chercheurs bénévoles de bureau fait que
regarder ces mots clics le il ya aucune
indication d'activité de robots ou quoi
que ce soit finalement jeff tout ça nous
démontre encore une fois que politiques
et technologies ne font pas toujours bon
ménage
mais non et cette application le c'était
supposé d'être la réponse du parti
démocrate à la puissance dans notre
champ en ce qui a trait à l'utilisation
de technologies pour gagner des
élections et s'est incliné échec total
et et plus loin que ça on apprend dans
notre temps parce qu'elle l'application
on le
conçu en moins de deux mois avant les
primes alors il ya des gens qui ont
trouvé là dessus qu'ils n'avaient pas
beaucoup d'expérience pour créer de
l'infrastructure informatique pour
gagner des élections
ça n'a aucun bon sens il ya eu une foi
aveugle envers la technologie
ça crée un climat qui n'est bon pour
absolument personne c'est à miner la
crédibilité ou parti démocrate mais
aussi envers le processus démocratique
au conflit aux états unis ce qui est
erroné que là dedans c'est qu'il ya
toujours des inquiétudes que les russes
pourraient potentiellement piraté le
processus des caucus dans le parti
démocrate mais non c'est une application
développée pour le parti démocrate qui
est en compte
ouais c'est prometteur pour la suite les
calculs c'est les primaires c'est le
début du cycle on verra quels correctifs
seront apportés